all right i got more falcon in the
winter soldier to talk about before we
do i want to thank the sponsor of this
video this video is brought to you by
your sad heartbroken comments about my
hair however in my defense i didn't know
it was a time of
familiar things disappearing on youtube
my long hair goes away
youtube trying to make the dislike
button go away but to be fair one of
those things
is insanely stupid and the other just
grows back over time
but now falcon and the winter soldier
this is the episode of falcon in the
winter soldier where things start to
i don't want to say happen because
things have been happening but it gets
real
i mean point is zemo comes into the fold
which they break him out and i thought
okay this episode's going to be
basically a prison break episode but it
just kind of fast forwards through it
was like okay
so now zemo's out by the way so now you
know sam and i was thinking at the time
and to be honest i'm still thinking
getting zemo out of prison could have
been a whole episode could have been a
whole prison break episode i probably
would have been pretty engaged
worst case scenario they have one extra
episode
of falcon in the winter soldier one
extra week of youtubers talking about it
not a bad thing for them so i don't know
why they didn't do that point is
now he's out and i gotta say they're
using
zemo very well he's great because in
captain america civil war
zema was kind of eclipsed by the
conflict at hand i get that he was
the one who was the catalyst that got
captain america civil war to happen but
it was oh team cap or team iron man
there was no hashtag team zemo
that i saw now who knows there might
very well be because zemo's amazing
doesn't hurt that daniel bruhl's a great
actor sure but they're using
zemo well he's not just like oh a
villain or the villain he's a wild card
he's a villain
but as bucky said he's like but he has a
code that code being yeah
get the avengers to try to kill each
other so
yeah bucky his code is anti-you but
maybe that makes bucky truly objective
like we need his help though that
probably makes sam truly
logical where it's like leave him in
prison it's
fine i don't think we should spring the
person
who literally killed king t'chaka i just
wakanda remembers that [ __ ] you want the
most technologically advanced
country on the planet on your ass for
springing the one who killed their
leader
go for it i'm out but zemo's already out
by the time he figured out maybe that's
why they
sped past the whole like all right we're
not gonna dedicate a whole episode to
zemo getting out or getting sprung from
prison because sam
definitely wouldn't have been a part of
that [ __ ] because it wasn't but now
damage done he's out so
he has to be so the three of them are
rolling they're palling around
not really pals but now that zemo's in
the forefront you see how he just [ __ ]
with people's heads he's just
little whispers that mess with you kind
of like hannibal lecter meets magneto
you know magneto from x-men two when
he's talking to pyro and he was like
what's your name and pyro's like john
he's like
what's your real name john you like [ __ ]
like that
that's what zemo does also love the
super seedy criminal black market
place like i just love super seedy
underworld criminal hangouts
in any entertainment whether it be mass
effect final fantasy vii remake
here in falcon winter soldier i see
these places and just
the smell is always the same it's
popcorn weed and
crime see someone packing up what looks
like heisenberg's blue
you know all the neon the ambience i was
like i could hang out here i mean
hypothetically
in a fake world i'm just saying if
someone wants to make a vr experience
called super seedy
futuristic criminal underground hangout
i would just i'd be there forever well
isn't jeremy doing videos oh [ __ ] that
super cd criminal hangout vr experience
came out he's probably hanging out there
i do have questions in terms of public
perception of bucky barnes
and the winter soldier and where those
lines fade and best i can figure like
the common folk you and me probably
don't know much about the winter soldier
and if it was on a newsreel or a sizzle
reel they wouldn't recognize him i mean
he got a haircut that helps with that
but if i like
if i pass ted kaczynski on the street i
wouldn't i wouldn't recognize him and
that's the una bombers
you know like not a lot of people
recognize criminals if they pass them on
the street
however i feel like criminals should
know more about that and so
the story i mean that was big news when
king tachaka was killed and it was
pegged on bucky but then t'challa
captured zemo after he found out wait a
minute this guy actually did it and he
framed bucky
and then zemo's in prison so you would
think there was due process and a court
date
and you know like i feel like the whole
winter soldier thing was probably
brought up
and if the common person was like well
yeah i don't care
i feel like criminals should take note
of like wait a minute you mean
winter soldier isn't really winter
soldier anymore you would think that
would have been
information somewhere so when all these
criminals like oh it's the winter
soldier and zemo's like i'll give you
the winter soldier and the codes to
control him i feel like someone in the
criminal underworld
who wants to live should probably keep
tabs on that
and the fact that the winter soldier's
not the winner soldier anymore and
whether or not they do or don't or
should or shouldn't
it's just a thought that i had um not as
prevalent in my mind
as the real thought would captain
america have gotten canceled on twitter
for being friends with the winter
soldier
because i think he would have i think we
live in a world where cap would have
gotten cancelled on twitter
there you go that's for your mind to
melt
on but all that aside it falls apart not
because someone recognizes the fact that
wait that's bucky and bucky's not the
winter soldier anymore
no it's because sam didn't do what i
always do like
none of my friends or family can get in
touch with me because my phone's
always on silent and i'm sure that
frustrates them
to no end however if i'm ever trying to
infiltrate some super cd underground i
know for a fact that my cover will not
be blown
because someone calls me like what
happened here why did sam have his phone
on why was his phone on silent
why was his phone on him at all this guy
is an accomplice
to springing zemo he's hanging out with
someone
who killed the leader of wakanda pretty
sure
someone can track his phone if they
really wanted to dude leave that [ __ ] at
home good to see sharon carter though
who's in a completely different place
than we saw her last cause she was like
yeah
i wasn't with the avengers i didn't get
my little pardon or anything so i'm just
in a world of crime and selling art
goods
what aunt peggy approve of that do you
think she thinks that every time she's
selling her super cd art you think she's
like aunt peggy would not approve
i'm so sad neither would uncle steve
another thing i thought of steve rogers
went back in time
and then had that whole life with peggy
carter in which he probably knew sharon
carter and sharon carter probably knew
him as
uncle steve which makes some of the
steve rogers sharon carter dynamics
a little more awkward however if what
happened happened and you know steve
rogers was old and he was like yeah i
had this whole life
with peggy carter sharon carter probably
knew him you think sharon carter's like
dude
i knew steve more than any of you ever
will and there's just an interesting
dynamic
because of that time travel relationship
that steve had
with peggy carter that they could have
done with sharon carter
i don't think they will do but it would
be interesting if they did do
nonetheless she takes down a lot of
dudes like we're talking hotline miami
style i know john wick
is the easy thing to think of but i've
been playing a lot of hotline miami
lately and playing it a lot on the vita
viva la vita yeah i thought of hotline
miami
it's been on a kickoff like it was
clearly hotline miami and or jane wick
but i hope she doesn't sell them out you
know
she's like oh we have a couple of
problems i was like you're not talking
about
you're not talking about them are you
just don't come on oh yeah they sprung
zemo who killed king t'chaka from prison
sure and maybe that's your way of
getting back into the good graces of the
united states
or wakanda who will get you back in the
good graces of the united states or hell
wakanda [ __ ] dude retire there and
that's where it ends
with that which sam alluded to before
when he was like wakanda has not
forgotten
at the end there's this wakanda warrior
woman she's like where is he which
really puts bucky in a tough spot
because she came to bucky man she came
to the white wolf you know they really
helped bucky out
gave him the nickname the white wolf so
i mean that's going to be tough for him
to be like
it's complicated pretty sure they're not
going to take that answer
but i'm interested to see what happens
next but zemo coming
into the fold into the picture it really
adds a whole new dynamic to this show
the tension that's gonna bring between
wakanda in this whole thing it's
it's really fascinating stuff and it
really ramped up in this episode zemo
stole the episode
honestly if they keep it up he could
very well steal the show i was glad to
see him in his mask
though i feel like him in his mask was
just for fan service he was like oh i'm
gonna put on this mask
just because for a second because they
got to make an action figure of this
all right you got that hot toys great
cool all right so falcon in the winter
soldier episode 3
and zemo coming into it what did you
think about it how do you think it's
going to go down like not in this
episode
but going forward with zemo and all
those complications whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you